New York State getting inducted into the
International Boxing Hall of Fame he is
Jim Gray here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you Jim
I'm doing great rich how you doing so
you have accepted you have accepted the
invitation you are going to you're going
you are there right I am going yes and I
don't understand the thought process of
Tyrell well why be bitter and angry
they're honoring you for your excellence
and the commitment of excellence that
you achieve and to now go somewhat in
your nose is because of what you felt
was past lights which is probably true
he was slighted but it's time to get
over that and you got to be better
tomorrow than you were yesterday and he
should he should take the same step that
the Hall of Fame taught by inducting him
so I'm sorry to see it just that it just
you know it's it's a wonderful time an
amazing achievement it's going to be
that forever and the fact that he didn't
go when they're immortalizing him for
his achievements it's it's beyond sad
well anything really know how to
describe it well in terms of what you're
got going on there is there somebody
that presents you I mean what is the
Hall of Fame ceremony look like there
for this weekend Mike Tyson is going to
speak a few words in presenting me so
I've been associated with Mike for a
long time I love him personally
it was great to me professionally did
all those interviews he broke his back
to feeding Lennox Lewis his children
ripping his heart out to ear biting too
you name it we've been together for a
long time so I'm really honored that
Mike is coming back to Canastota hadn't
been here in quite some time he's from
upstate New York and he will make the
presentation tomorrow and is it the
scripted remarks Jim all these maroc
scripted from Mike Mike I can't tell you
what Mike's gonna say Mike's his own guy
I'm sure we'll have plenty of laughs and
it will be loose free and easy so a look
he's Mike Tyson and in many ways rich
being able for me to be able to stand
next to him at his greatest times and
that's his worst times was really you
know it was quite
right I don't even really know how else
to explain I mean walk me through that
Jim I imagine somebody got in your ear
it's humble I guess that's interesting
that I would even say something like
that but when when they get your ear and
say basically hey Mike just bit
Holyfield's ear off go and ask him
questions I mean see it that was
ringside so I I saw it right as it
happened as dude Steve Albert Ferdie
Pacheco uh during the fight and it just
became chaos and bedlam after that and
there was a mini riot in the ring and
the state troopers uh the Nevada State
Troopers got into the ring and Mills
Lane was there and I was interviewing
bills and the billy clubs came out and
then we followed it back into the locker
room and it was Don King who actually
procured the interview because I don't
know that Mike would have come out but
Don was walking in behind me with John
horn and worried all the way and I said
Don know these people have paid fifty
sixty dollars I forget what it was at
the time doesn't Mike Tyson owe them an
explanation for what's gone on and don't
you owe an explanation since you're
profiting from this if you said you're
right you do and he went and got him so
uh on the credits to Don King because
Don didn't
Don wanted to deliver and he knew that
the fans had paid and so he brought him
out and Tyson answered all the questions
one thing you can say about Mike rich
and you've been around all these
athletes for all of these years Mike
Tyson takes his own medicine he doesn't
blame anybody else for his actions when
he does something wrong he comes out and
faces the music and he's accountable and
so few are and so few do I find it
really quite admirable and and and I
have tremendous around respect for that
and a name that you just mentioned is a
fellow inductee Steve Albert's going
into the class for the Hall of Fame with
you Jim Gray joining us here from
Canastota New York where he's going to
be in the International Boxing Hall of
Fame and then obviously let's talk a
little bit more about some of the
interviews that you've had throughout
your career Jim do you regret any of
them any of the moments that you've had
one specific that you're like you know
what I'd change that if I took a second
shot at it I'd I don't regret any of
them rich I don't have a single regret
would I do better and could we all be
better on some of the instances that
have occurred and would I change some of
them yes of course
which one well I mean I think I've done
tens of thousands of interview I know
we're asking the point one out what
would I change you know I probably would
have you know everybody talks about the
Pete Rose interview and I think that's
what you're you're hinting at no no Jim
please I'm not hinting at a single thing
but go for I mean I think ya could have
been better and I think you know I could
have recognized the circumstance that we
were in you know and I didn't I made a
mistake that night by not watching the
television monitor I was in the dugout
with the New York Yankees at Atlanta
Stadium at the time and the whole
ceremony fell flat where I was watching
from because it was in shallow
centerfield just past second base and
you couldn't see Brooks Robinson hugging
Sandy Koufax and talking to Hank Aaron
and you couldn't hear the bell and
colleague violin music that was being
played in the background from where I
was so I wasn't looking at the monitor
so everybody at home was having a good
moment of what was going on and thinking
harkening back to a time that had gone
by of all of their heroes and then we
came on with this interview about Pete
and gambling so perhaps if I'd have been
watching the monitor it there would have
been a different tone I don't regret any
of the questions and I don't regret
anything about it
Pete is accountable for his actions but
the tone may have been a little
different if I'd have been watching
television as opposed to watching the
ceremony well interesting enough Jim is
I remember what you know and then Chad
Curtis saying to you on live television
castigating you for your line of
questioning with Pete Rose and walking
away I was supposed to interview Chad
Curtis after you were done with him for
ESPN Radio and I saw Chad Curtis
standing there waiting to go on camera I
think he set you up Jim quite frankly do
you Mark he did of course he did and you
know the sad thing for me is the Chad
Curtis and his family that's what he
looks back now his greatest moment ever
were a chance where he could have you
know really just had something to show
everybody associated with him forever
and he's wasting
I'm trying to merge me and castigate me
for something that had gone for gone 48
hours before your greatest moment in
your life he chose to handle it that way
look it looks like to me Chad Curtis and
I take no joy in saying this has made a
lot of bad decisions that was one of
them Jim Gray Boxing Hall of Fame
inductee here on the Rich Eisen show and
now you are front and center with so
much going on with Tom Brady Jim since
you interview him on Westwood One every
single Monday night and then the most
recent moment where you asked him about
his relationship in New England and he
pleaded the fifth what do you think tom
was pleading the fifth on a few weeks
ago
well I just I just think after 18 years
of anything okay
18 years of marriage 18 years of success
18 years with a business partner a coach
or anything you know when you've had all
of the success that they've had and
you've also had disappointments they've
lost three Super Bowls you know it's not
always easy and and and getting to those
points causes a lot of hard work and
dedication and it also brings out a lot
of emotions so Tom also said in that
interview he said look the people that I
work for are trying to bring out the
best in me and this is the way that they
go about it because they think that this
brings out the best in me so and look it
has he was the MVP last year and nobody
else has been to eight Super Bowls with
Tom Brady okay so something there
has gone very very right does that mean
that there aren't quirks and flaws and
pitfalls and and and potholes in this
entire process and that they probably
don't get on each other's nerves from
time to time I'm sure they do you know
we don't get to see all of that so you
know look all of us you've had bosses at
ESPN and the NFL Network and I am and
you said you how many Emmys if you want
zero gm0 damn it zero oh I'm sorry I
didn't mean I didn't know that but you
also don't know that you're being
Fantine on my television screen it's
11:00 time Emmy award-winner so keep
spiking
football army unbeknownst to you Jim
[Laughter]
fantastic but here's the thing you know
you'd like to be appreciated and and an
arm put around you instead of always
constantly you know trying to be gotten
the best out of so perhaps that's where
he was going I don't know it's only in
Thompson he only knows how he feels I
can't tell you how he feels and I can't
tell you how you feel only he knows how
he feels so at that moment when that
question was answered asked that time we
felt but yesterday said he had a good
relationship coach Belichick I'm sure
they do how can they not I mean you know
do they want to go to dinner and play
golf with each other every day no but
how many people do you take home that
you work with every day and say let's go
to dinner tonight let's go out and hit
the links tomorrow let's go play tennis
what about racquetball I mean it's a
working relationship and it's worked
very well a few more minutes here with
Jim Gray
on the Rich Eisen show and now LeBrons
got his decision coming up Jim any any
chance of decision - any chance that we
get you out there he's got a big one
coming up in July what do you think with
Lee Jenkins no it's true okay so
decision three folks were so unhappy
with ESPN and we're on on the decision
there was nothing different about
decision - it was just written it was
delivered through a media outlet it was
it was it was you know so where was the
uproar over that because the writers the
writers had one of their own to it as
opposed to one of us so there was no
difference the difference is the
hypocrisy so I don't know how the bran
will choose to let the world know this
time I haven't asked him I wish him the
best
he's been tremendously loyal as maverick
Carter and rich Paul and Randy MEMS to
me and you know I hope he finds a place
where he can go where he'll able to be
well how little to continue this pursuit
of this astonishing career this
miraculous career that we've all been
able to enjoy so that's a no but I don't
know that he knows I don't think that he
knows that ain't people say it's Los
Angeles Philadelphia he's not a Houston
or maybe Miami's back in them so he may
just stay where he's at
I mean anybody who tells you that he's
just guessing cuz no one knows because I
don't think that he knows I agree and so
that's a no there will be no decision
three with Jim Gray and LeBron James is
what you're saying there will be another
last one for you Jim I mean you were the
reporter during malice in the palace I
mean we just talked about the the the
decision with LeBron and all the stuff
with the you know Pete Rose baseball I
mean and now here you are going into the
Boxing Hall of Fame I mean to what do
you owe being at in the middle of so
much of your career Jim well I've had
the good fortune to be employed by a lot
of people and have been at the right
place at the right time and you know
hard work and dedication and I've had
great relationships I've had tremendous
relationships and I wouldn't trade my
life and my circumstance with anybody on
the planet I'm really fortunate really
lucky and so I attributed the whole
confluence of events to what I just said
and luck I mean you know you can't you
know you can't pick yourself for all of
this I mean I you can't you say hey I
want to be in the Hall of Fame and then
they put you in I know we had our test
here just a couple weeks ago he said
he's become friends with the fan that
through you know the beer Adam that
started the whole thing off it's just
unbelievable some of these stories and
how they've turned out Jim and that's
what happens rich you know you just you
just don't know in life I'm gonna say it
tomorrow in my speech or Sunday in my
speech that I never would have thought
that all of these things could have
happened but I never particularly ever
remotely contemplated the fact that I
would be standing next to a man who bit
off another man's ear and that that
and would become one of my best friends
and one of the people who I most respect
and admire and I'm genuinely happy every
time I'm in his company Jim really
appreciate the time congratulations on
bacteria on your induction and I'm
hoping I get to you know even within ten
of your Emmy total at some point well
thanks for having me on you do a great
job Susie and I hope yes best two best
to you and yours as well Jim Gray
congratulations on the Boxing Hall of
Fame right there the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience